again okay
playing woody glass again so let's do
one of the normal and one of the normal
things here with white he's playing with
night bg7 right they place the the
straight main line here with where b5 is
possible but I'm not really an expert on
that so with b5 and c6 and so on I just
play the the normal the normal
continuation so what to do here this is
black has really good equalizing chances
here but this is the the nature of that
line I play that with black myself
and there's really not much that I can
do about it
okay Queen B - I guess no then you will
take home to take on c5 what happens if
I take and go b5 now take c6 and before
what exactly MMC six before I can do
Knight a - then okay let's do it
maybe Queen eight five no no you just
place the simple stuff
not that this is bad I mean just the
simple continuation it takes on if I
take on v6 he maybe has c5 that actually
is somewhat interesting take on c6 Queen
c6 cannot take on b6 here Queen C 3 is
hitting okay yes c5 is interesting but
as usually plays the boring move this is
really what sometimes is irritating he
never even tries to play something
remotely interesting he's just totally
okay with trading down everything and
play a super boring endgame Jack yeah
like a witty one he will take it in 100%
of the cases check yeah he will actually
absolute absolutely do that
and yet simply nothing is going on
what about the time I'm slightly behind
just slightly
if I go f4 it's got Bishop d6 shouldn't
do that look at this I don't know it's
really nothing going on
hmm there any kind of idea with this I
don't know probably not
and sometimes the problem he really just
didn't do does nothing and shuffles
around with no particular purpose and
then all of a sudden there is an idea
and you have to be alert to spot that
ticking that doesn't really change the
situation at all
check yeah so not very exciting but it's
really difficult to get an exciting game
against him maybe I should pre much more
to be quicker check-check
I don't know maybe I should just sit and
do nothing I mean I'm not doing much
more than that admittedly check I'm some
work behind behind on the clock this is
a bit unsettled draw either just drawing
if there's some kind of 3/4 that I
didn't see warning
it's not even having a symbolic
advantage she or anything
Alfred ah he just he just is a total
[ __ ] it's really anything else would be
too friendly his only purpose is and to
shuffle around completely aimlessly and
try to do it on time check check check
game drawn yeah
125 moves German was difficult and you
get get anything going
and you really place this kind of
there's some kind of fun everything -
yes
yeah it's not much to a device it was
just all the way equal and nothing
nothing happens really it could have
been agreed to drawn here but it just
took 100 moves to to get it get it done
anyway thanks for watching